andrés muchas gracias por la invitación
y con relación a su pregunta diría que
el presidente del bando que recibió un
país que estaba en un proceso de
transformación de cambio que suponía la
implementación de los acuerdos de paz
pero un país dividido polarizado en
torno a la idea efectivamente de llevar
a cabo la implementación de ese acuerdo
o no el presidente y de iván duque
además enfrentaba una situación
económica muy compleja por la que ya
describían muy bien en la nota y fue
incapaz de recoger esos esas demandas y
esas inconformidades sociales y esa
situación social que se estaba
presentando así como incapaz de llevar
adelante una implementación adecuada de
ese proceso de paz con la antigua
guerrilla de las farc y por ello el
gobierno del bando que se caracteriza
digamos por una
inconsistencia reconocida a nivel
internacional en el discurso tren a
nivel internacional ya nivel
doméstico en materia precisamente en la
implementación de los acuerdos de paz en
materia de promoción y protección de los
derechos humanos especialmente en ese
contexto de agitación política y social
específicamente en lo que se denominó
con el estallido social que se ha
llevado de manera intermitente en los
últimos años por diferentes grupos
sociales que se han movilizado para
expresar estas inconformidades y también
por otros asuntos como la protección y
promoción del medio ambiente esa
inconsistencia en el discurso además se
ha sumado a su fracaso en materia de
seguridad y por supuesto el acuerdo de
paz suponía también una transición en la
que había una disminución de la
violencia pero donde por supuesto los
grupos armados
iban a copar los espacios que dejaban la
antigua guerrilla de las farc yo suponía
entonces un nuevo incremento en la
violencia en el gobierno de bandula que
no fue capaz de enfrentar esos retos y
otros tantos que se presentaron a lo
largo de su periodo por eso lo que
encuentra hoy el país lo que dejará el
guandú que es una sociedad ansiosa por
iniciar un nuevo período presidencial
ahora teniendo en cuenta la gestión del
mandatario en estos temas que usted
acaba de mencionar qué retos tendrá que
asumir el nuevo presidente muy
brevemente por favor
el nuevo presidente entre los más
opcionados
posiblemente gustado petro federico
gutiérrez
recientemente se habla de rodolfo
hernández como potencial el tercero en
el este en esta contienda electoral no
sería bajarlo en cuarto lugar van a
encontrar un país y sobre todo expresado
en la conformación del legislativo muy
dividido para tener dificultades de
gobernabilidad muy serias porque ninguna
de las tendencias políticas ha logrado
tener una mayoría y por tanto va a tener
muchas reclamen está des en avanzar una
agenda legislativa
en este nuevo período